I really it will he everyone is shut up
everyone is shut up
we're trying to film everyone shut up
hey guys I'm Ryan right this is my
female friend right here okay I have a
question for you guys should she change
her name to salamander or salamander
salad that's the big debate right now in
my life we'll see anyway um there's this
a thing out video I guess where everyone
keeps saying watch the shrek is life
shrek is love trailer no idea what it is
I really don't and Sally and I argued
for like 15 minutes about which one was
the right video to click and I hope we
got the right one if not it's on Sally
not me it just doesn't read general so I
figured that was the right one and it
was the one that people reacted to are
do you react so that's my argument
whatever okay whatever just don't [__]
with me Sally let's do this we're
feeling it's not a legit thing though I
think it's just a bowel video that's
weird
let's find out I was only nine years old
I love to segment I had all the
merchandise and movies a very district
every night before bed thanking him for
the life of me
[Music]
this is ready
[Laughter]
[Music]
these commits suicide what the [__] was
that this is a strange video but I love
it no it's like weirdly creative like
the most disturbing creative you know
difficult that was to make like I'm
sorry I'm sorry I just don't understand
someone could take like you know how
long it takes to make the short films
like that using that type of CGI they
probably work months on this thing yes
it was well worth it it was well made
really yeah it was [__] funny
a little disturbing but funny that was
really just sort of that was exactly
what I expected from a viral video oh my
god I I thought that like would the way
how you and Nick Matt that you would
identify with the way this story played
out this is like this is kind of a
shocker to me really no no I know yeah
why not
no Sally come on anal is awesome
I wouldn't know I've seen a lot of porn
hmm yeah and I just feel like I just saw
one as well oh yeah that was crazy I
hope they make a sequel maybe we could
make a petition about you being in the
sequel see you were born okay verdict on
that I'm gonna have nightmares so I
didn't like that that was like that's up
there with salad fingers yeah I mean I
hate saw the fingers you did I did I'm
sweating a lot right now every time I
see stop it stop making me sweat okay
tone down the whole tooth thing and then
BAM I'll stop sweating I'm
oh she brought it back and he broke the
back anyway guys if you're new to the
channel hit this button up here to
subscribe should be green like ass
yeah Shrek's ass listen guys Sally needs
a camera oh so yeah can you give me some
money to give to Sally that's the way it
works okay I just put up the video on my
channel explaining why I haven't been
able to put up videos and it's because I
don't have the camera and he lives
frickin far away and gas money and my
life right now is crazy and so I can't
do videos as much so I need a camera I
could help you relax that did it for me
that video I'm good but so anyway if you
want to contribute you can click a link
down below look Sally okay it's the most
important time of the video yes and what
time of the video is that Sally oh maybe
this is something like subscribers
Janice remember think about the doping
mother stop I'm getting a boner I'm
gonna let Sally take the first one okay
this one is from Eric rod ah he said or
who died on mmm he said hey Sally give
me a shout-out beautiful wow I'm really
really happy that you spelled all of
those words correctly because usually in
YouTube comments you all sound like
idiot all you thank you I appreciate
that and I like how in your thumbnail
it's just like dramatic and then red I
hope you're okay if you're depressed
message me and also new happy face I'm
sorry but Eric cool thank you for that
Julie canal now she actually didn't ask
for a shout-out but I noticed she
comments a lot and I cannot reply back
to her
count for some reason and she looks
rather cute actually I want you to get
any Carol where we could talk to each
other okay Julie but the way your name
spelled I hope you're not from
indonesians really cool cuz that's far I
have no problem being Indonesian I could
travel to Germany ooh
come to California hackers slash he said
can you do a reaction on the following
they named a bunch of [__] please and a
shout out names
Stan Lee lives in New Zealand and you're
awesome
no no so your name's Stanley Stanley I
like that name from success like old
kids show Stanley with his like book of
adventures and he's Australian yeah it's
a great big book of everything with
everything inside this book no I want to
go there it's if you've seen Lord of the
Rings I hear it's exactly the same thing
really yeah that's what I heard too so
oh wait for college I'm gonna do
work-study program there just to go to
New Zealand oh I should visit you yeah
visit hacker / great idea we're done we
know I remember done you